Pixar just loves to load its animated
movies with Easter eggs and hidden
details and there are stacks of them you
might have missed when you first watch
cars three yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and we've cast three
available now to watch at home I've gone
through the movie with a fine-tooth comb
and today I'll be explaining all the
Pixar Easter eggs and cool details
hidden in the film also I'm starting a
new Disney Funko giveaway for one of
these cars pop figures for a chance to
win make sure you're subscribed to my
channel and leave me a comment about
your favorite Easter eggs you spotted in
the movie and just a quick warning
before we start I'll be discussing
spoilers from cars 3 so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet cruises
license plate is a clever shout-out to
the actress cristela Alonzo who voices
the character in the movie it's a
combination of her initials C na and
then her birthday January the 6th plus
the plate is registered in text gasp a
pun on Texas which is where Alonso was
born the sleepwell motel from Toy Story
of terror also shows up in cars 3 on a
giant roadside advert above the bridge
where Mack and lightning spend the night
after the Thunder Hollow incident
the sign says time to retire which
reflects lightning state of mind at that
moment as he's just had an argument with
Cruz after she won the demolition derby
and he's thinking about giving up racing
for good but it's also an extra
reference to Toy Story of terror and how
Bonnie's mum had to stay at the
sleepwell motel after she got a flat
tire
also on that billboard there's a deep
cut Easter Egg to Pixar's incorporation
date in the number 0 to 0 386 in other
words February the 3rd 1986 and while
Mac is sleeping below the bridge inside
Lightning is flipping channels and just
for a moment the Cars 2 scene of a
couple kissing on the pandas are in
Paris pops up on the TV screen by the
way those kissing cars are named John
and Nancy after Pixar's John Lasseter
and his wife whose favorite color just
happens to be lavender the same as a
female car in that scene one of the most
memorable moments in cars 3 is a
demolition derby race where we meet the
fearsome Miss fritter and the scenes at
the Thunder Hollow Speedway are also a
fantastic treasure trove of Pixar Easter
eggs and references for fans to
appreciate
during the contest one of the
competitors bill gets pushed along by
Miss fritter and his color design is the
same as Pixar's famous luxo ball plus he
even has the luxo ball painted on his
hood the luxo ball appeared in Pixar's
very first short film luxo jr. together
with two desk lamps one of which is
still used in Pixar's logo another
competitor at the Thunder Hollow
demolition derby is the Pizza Planet
truck aka Todd who has appeared in both
of the previous two cars movies and in
cars three at one point a car goes
crashing into him which knocks the Pizza
Planet rocket off his roof and send it
flying into the crowd a 3/8 racer called
t-bone whose body is kind of twisted as
a street sign at the front of his hood
in the race the sign reads Park Avenue a
shout-out to the location of Pixar
animations main office at twelve-hundred
Park Avenue Emeryville miss prissy is of
course the queen of the track at Thunder
Hollow and the design of her smokestacks
are a deliberate or march to the horns
of the classic Disney villain Maleficent
and dotted around the speedway are a
number of billboards which have some
super Sneaky Easter eggs hidden within
them there's a car life-insurance ad by
a company called insurer he care which
is the same insurance company that Bob
works for in The Incredibles
and the Wild Bill's racing cones
billboard is a reference to the Cars
three production designer Bill Cohn and
the radio station wild 86.2 FM is
another deep cut Easter Egg to the month
and year when Pixar was incorporated
February 1986 by the way there's yes
another nod to that year in the movie is
a number of bill the luxo ball car is 86
and 1986 is also the year that Pixar
release their first short film look so
junior which also featured the luxo ball
in 1986 it was Steve Jobs he provided
the investment money for Pixar spin-out
as a corporation from Lucasfilm and
since then Pixar have included numerous
Amara's in their movies too Steve Jobs
most famous brand Apple in cars 3 you
can hear the Mac starting sound when
crews boots up the treadmill on fireball
Beach
oh okay you might also have heard the
same sound in wall-e as it plays after
Wally has finished charging himself
speaking of Wally there's an Easter Egg
to that movie by the BNL aka by enlarge
track sponsor at one of the speedway's
BNL is a corporation in wall-e that
basically enabled the pollution of the
planet and sent humans away from Earth
while it attempted to clear it up a VNL
raceway logo also appears during the
Cars three credits Pixar's films always
include Easter eggs for their next movie
which in the case of car 3 means Coco
and there are loads of Coco Easter eggs
and references in cars three for example
you can spot the guitar from Coco on the
stage behind sweet tea and hair band at
the cotter pin bar the town where Coco
is set Santa Cecilia appears on the
treadmill screen at the Rusty's Racing
Center when one of the homesick cars
thinks of home and there's also a neat
Coco inspired brand of liquor in the bar
where Miss fritter and her friends go to
watch the Florida 500 race the brand
advertised is Tour Keller which is a
clever car based per non-talk and
tequila while miss fritters in that bar
you'll need to look very carefully to
spot a sneaky a113 Easter Egg via one of
the license plates hanging on the side
of the school bus and you can see that a
bit more clearly during the Crazy eight
demolition derby as well miss Frizzle
collects license plates from the
opponents she defeats at the Thunder
Hollow Speedway and she also seems to
collect street signs and one of those
street signs is her West cutting
Boulevard a reference to the street
address of Pixar's former headquarters
in Richmond California other cars three
a113 Easter eggs include one on the
press sticker that track reporter
Shannon spokes was on her side and
there's a fairly obvious a one one three
on the daughter Sterling's office at the
Rusty's Racing Center and inside
Sterling's office there are some more
cool Easter eggs hidden among the
trophies on his shelves is Cinderella's
pumpkin carriage the movies set
department included this as it's a four
wheeled vehicle and is a fun little nod
to one of Disney's classic films
and this one is much harder to see but
if you look very carefully you'll see
there's a small picture of sir miles
Axelrod the villain from Cars 2 which
might suggest that Stirling once knew
the evil mastermind from the second Cars
movie the miniature tree on Sterling's
desk also looks a lot like the tree from
a bug's life which is also appeared
previously in up and Toy Story 2 and
before Lightning went to the Rusty's
Racing Center who spoke on a payphone
two rusty and dusty from Radiator
Springs
now that payphone was originally
designed to appear and the first Cars
movie was ended up being cut in fact
when cars three production designer Jeju
ster joined Pixar back in the early
2000s that pay phone was one of the very
first things he created during the
Florida 500 race one of the races spins
out of control nearly causing a multiple
car accident
the spinning car is number 31 and its
sponsor is triple dense gum which is the
chewing gum from inside outs that had a
recurring jingle that played throughout
that movie now what was your favorite
moment or Easter egg in cars three and
were there any other cool details you
spotted that I missed let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe as well for a chance to win a
Disney Cars three Funko pop I'll
probably announce the winner on one of
my upcoming cocoa videos next month so
make sure you have notifications and
able to get all my new videos as soon as
they're ready and if you enjoyed this do
hit that thumbs up button and take a
look at some more Pixar and other videos
you might like right here thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers